sur une planche
c'est du monde comme les autres avec son
film répertoire des villes disparu le
réalisateur denis côté de vionnaz boni
du festival international du film de
berlin
il en sera à sa cinquième présence de
tests d'unanimité ch allergique aux
conventions et ce fim leur rentrer
dedans
ce que j'aime faire c'est cette
signature qui permet au cinéaste de 45
ans de se tailler une place dans le
circuit des festivals de films
internationaux
son long métrage curling a concouru au
festival du film de locarno en suisse
ses films vic et flo ont vu un ours et
boris ans béatrice ont tous les deux
étaient en compétition à berlin
surtout ils ont un respect pour mon
travail je m'entends très bien que les
allemands y avait une logique à y
retourner
retournez à berlin pour y présenter son
tout dernier long métrage répertoire des
villes disparu librement inspiré du
roman de laurence olivier dans un petit
village le décès de nadau provoque le
retour des morts notre brave ci est
tombé au combat
l'arrivée des morts aussi ça ça vient
peut chavirer tout là le quotidien je
pense que c'est quand même c'est bien
fait parce que si on aurait pu devenir
ait pu faire comme des zombies cm ces
retenues
je pense que c'est ça devient plus
symbolique dans ce drame fantastique et
de genre une distribution imposante
donnent la réplique dans une ruralité
appelés à disparaître pour la sélection
de ces acteurs denis côté ne passe pas
par les canaux habituels
je crois pas du tout dans l'idée des
auditions joints des acteurs qui pense
d'avoir mois avec des numéros pige les
notes comme la petite école c'est non
j'ai tellement pas d'animaux ima procès
sur les réseaux sociaux
à quelques jours de présenter son film à
berlin le cinéaste espère que la
reconnaissance viennent aussi d'ici si
je pouvais enfin avons un film qui
rejoint un peu plus grand public au
québec chez moi au lieu de toujours
aller me faire voir ailleurs c'est sûr
que ça ferait plaisir et j'aime les
films arrivent sur nos écrans le 15
février
ici julie jocelyne boudreault radio
canada
montréal les gens vont oublier